when I tried to read mathematics it
would take an hour a page and I'd get
some of the ideas but not others and
usually it would be six months later
that suddenly it would click and so I
think guys thought of myself as sort of
slow but I never grew up in some sense
and as far as I can tell I've been
getting better at things slowly and
steadily it was only when I was older
that I noticed that most people do
something wonderful and then they get
stuck and I started to make theories of
why do people get stuck and how to avoid
it and the best thing is to if you've
done something you should be ashamed of
it instead of proud of it and I notice a
lot of people keep saying well I thought
of that a long time ago and and they
keep trying to get recognition and why
bother